[Music]
last weekend police were investigating a
mass shooting that erupted in a major
area of austin that left one man dead
and 14 others wounded police say the
shooting was prompted by a dispute
between
two groups and most of the victims were
simply bystanders
really awful to hear i hope they all
make a full and speedy recovery
last week police were investigating a
mass shooting that erupted in a major
area of wait no i just read this card
wally no no
look at it again this is a different one
wait another shooting on the same night
apparently there were four mass
shootings across the country last
weekend
so tragic my god that's awful
all this gun violence makes me feel
terrible i wish the country was more
committed to
taking steps that would wait are you
guys getting deja vu
yeah this all feels super familiar
hold on a second hey roll a clip from
the monologue from 20 years ago
last weekend police were investigating a
mass shooting that erupted
in a major area of hold up wally bro
we just read this ish nah nah look at it
close to my peeps this is another one
wait another shooting on the same night
apparently there were hella mass
shootings across the country last
weekend
bummer city dude oh damn that's whack
all this gun violence is so sick not
it'd be the bomb if our country ever
tried to wait
are you guys getting deja vu yeah for
shizzle this all feels super familiar
hold on a second roll a clip of the
monologue from 20 years ago
last weekend police were investigating a
mass shooting that erupted in a major
area of
hold up wall dog i already read this
take a chill pill ex-lax
this is another one wait another
shooting
on the same night apparently there were
a gnarly amount of shootings last
weekend
super heavy dudette gag me with a spoon
that is so grody all this gun violence
makes me want to ralph it would be so
tubular if our country ever tried to
wait
are you guys getting deja vu major
this all feels soup smell familial
that means familiar get with the times
broseph
hold on a second roll a clip of the
monologue from 20 years ago
last weekend police were investigating a
mass shooting that erupted in a major
area of
now just hold on a gosh darn minute
wally i
already read this cool your jets love
this here's another one isn't it wait
another shooting
on the same night dig this ruffarino
there were mad shootings last weekend
what a drag
drat all this gun violence has me
wigging out
it would be so primo if our country ever
tried to tackle this problem in a
meaningful way
that would be nito no i mean it
what if our politicians don't take this
problem seriously
what if even though people keep getting
hurt they don't pass any meaningful gun
control legislation and
what if we're still dealing with this
exact problem
60 years from now that would be crazy
almost as crazy as two black people
having their own tv show in 1961.
that's all right right on
[Music]
you